Schmidt. I got you something, man.
They didn't have a Jewish star at the store.
So I got you a regular cookie and I made the
star myself by breaking off the pieces. It's
meant to celebrate your Jewish heritage.
What is this?
The Jewish star. I just said that.
Hey, Schmidt, just.
This is so terrible.
You gave me cookie, I gave you cookie.
You gave me cookie, gave you cookie.
Gave me cookie, got you cookie. You gave me cookie, I got you cookie, man. Gave me cookie, got you cookie.
We're even. We're even, Schmidt. I
mean, what do you want from me? What do you
want, Schmidt? I've been racking my brain all
day. I walked around the grocery store, man,
for 45 minutes.
I didn't know what to get you. Then I was
thinking I was going to get you ramen like we
used to eat. But you probably eat like, fancy
ramen now with, like, figs in it. I don't
know, man. You love me too much, Schmidt.
And you picked the wrong guy. And when are
you going to get that through that giant head of yours?
I'm just going to let you down, man.
Are you crying?
I'm not crying.
Yeah, you are crying.
Oh, my God.
I'm not crying. Guys, just drop it. I
just felt like I did something nice.
Yes, you are.
And that's okay.
Don't say that, man, because that. You know
what I mean.
Just let it rain, man.
I got you the cookie, Schmidt. That's the best I
can do, man.
What about the turtle?
You're the only turtle I want. You're the
turtle, man.
I knew I was the turtle.
Yeah, man, You're the turtle.
You're the turtle.
You guys are the best, man.
I love you guys. I'm sorry. Sorry, man.
I'm going to.
Eat my sandwich right here. This is a good
sandwich. See, you guys.
This needed to happen.